righteous mind
Jonathan height yeah isn't there a
subtitle subtitle like why politics and
religion divide good people why good
people here we go
disagree about politics and religion
yeah yeah yeah and that's brought up in
your video about persuasion persuasion
yeah and that's not even the half of it
in my video that's a very basic like
overview of it because the book starts
with talking about the elephant and the
rider mm-hmm and the elephant and the
rider is about your emotional impulsive
reaction to things and the rider is your
rationality assessment of a situation
kind of thing and he just talks about
how the elephant the emotion is much
stronger ninety nine percent of a
hundred percent then we think we assume
more just do you somewhere you know
rational controlling everything but he
says you know that's not true
a lot of it is you actually coming in
with your all of your bias and all and
he describes it as moral taste buds of
things and your reaction to that will
immediately color how you see facts and
opinions and all information so the
reason in persuasion why it's so
important to establish common ground is
if you're just shouting at you know a
no-face on the internet there's no
connection with the 99% the l a-- had
the elephant at all right and so
everybody's yelling at each other trying
to be rational but they never establish
any commonality between each other it's
just these strangers who think they're
you know holier than thou or smarter
than the other person but it's just
basically words that are not connecting
with either side and usually the
assumption is if i can just put together
the perfect argument i can be as rude or
distasteful as i want and they will just
come over to my side because of my you
know your incredible intelligence
you know maybe there's a small subset of
the population who is looking for that
who is like oh I only like really
insightful I an see ite insight you know
people who have insight like you know
anger and things like that
with truth but in terms of the general
population convincing people has got to
get on the same side first whether that
even be something like we share the same
taste in TV shows and this would imply
that either we need to change the way
that we talk about like things like
politics or like religion and into his
book but or that we've just decided that
we don't care about convincing each
other and we're just kind of shouting
well within our tribe exactly and that's
also a big part of the book too which is
sort of like because of social
intuitionist theory which argues that
our ability to reason has nothing to do
with finding truth it has to do with
bringing people into our group it's the
same idea it's I'm only saying this
because I want to tighten my own tribe
right it has very little to do with
finding the truth between tribes so
that's the social intuition in this
theory and that's why when you read it
it's kind of it's sad because you're
like wow it's really hard to argue
across these tribal divides yeah because
people are their intuitions are
different like so much so that they
don't know they're different I think one
of the most interesting parts that I got
to in that book was he starts talking
about these post hoc reasons for like
justifying your biases and believing
that those reasons are built on some
level of like absolute truth and it
makes sense of why on both sides of the
fence there are things that will defend
about our group that are kind of Lee
morally kind of morally reprehensible
and so it seems to me like what seems to
be like a hypocritical
stance actually is just this playing out
exactly how you'd expect it to a hundred
percent yeah yeah it just plays out when
you see all controversy on the internet
if you put it through that framework you
you understand why there's so much
hypocrisy in politics and religion
because the writer is there to justify
behavior regardless of whether it fits
into like a set of principles it's it's
simply there to justify what what has
been done and people are really good and
it's interesting to me something I
realize is actually the smarter you are
the better you are fooling yourself and
like the more sophisticated your
arguments can get and the more you can
obfuscate abs abs obvious take up
sophisticate the fact that you are
actually serving this you know purpose
I think there's yeah it there's thing
like people don't have ideas ideas have
people anyway that's what I think of or
ideologies or moral tastebuds of people
yeah I totally agree with that like this
I think the smarter people tend to be
able to justify pretty much anything
they want because they're able to create
these really highfalutin arguments like
whenever they need to right you know
[Music]